je vois passer en salle et paul m il va
nous faire un résumé de tout ce qui
s'est passé à la télé hier adrien
lemaître iphone
[Applaudissements]
adrien c'est votre première chronique et
ils avaient été très très bons pilotes
c'est pour ça qu'on aime et j'entends
des gens étaient peu quand même à
l'antenne annonces étaient des pilotes
[Rires]
là beaucoup de gens qui médite sur
twitter pourquoi t'es kelly et auto tata
ne vous inquiétez pas elle sera de
retour derrière elle était un petit peu
malade
voilà vous le savez donc elle avait
besoin de rester un petit peu à six car
voilà elle est à côté et on ne voulait
pas le salir
on en sait m est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire ce que vous allez bien le concept
un danseur on savait pas le maître on va
retrouver toutes les infos qu'on ne
savait pas où mettre dans l'émission
mais il ya des experts parce que ce soir
je vais vous révéler les meilleurs mais
aussi les pierres audiences hier soir
j'ai des infos sur david hallyday j'ai
suivi l'itinérance des manuels macron et
surtout j'ai un gros scoop sur un grand
animateur qui va quitter une grande
chaîne pour une autre grande chaîne
un animateur je peux vous dire qu'il
n'est pas très loin sur ce plateau n'ont
quitté une grande chaîne mais sur tf1 à
mon avis à marc jean oui alors marc
chansons
il faut traverser là à l'elysée par
cadre est parti pour les audiences parti
pour les hommes et un jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez vers soir c'était un énorme carton
pour good doctor le premier épisode qui
pour un fou était le seul inédit de la
soirée a réuni 5,8 millions de
téléspectateurs
je vous ai fait le résumé de la soirée
good doctor regardez c'est bien c'est
une excellente idée
alors qu'est ce qu'on attend là on a eu
d'abord un dessinez c'est gagné
on a eu comme d'hab démo de médecine
qu'on comprend pas des combats milan 5o
ans kaléidoscopique la milice martic
stone ton dos vasculaire dilatation des
buts en aval de la racine aortique
ils nous ont même fait des mois en rimes
ligne de la trinitrine et là on essaie
de stimuler son père avec de la cocaïne
là je la démens compliqué c'est toujours
le docteur sean murphy qui nous écrase
japon créateur graphie rétrograde
endoscopique dans cette série les
médecins ils ont tellement de travail
qui sont obligés de manger en opérant et
avenue denfert avec des sushis on est
des raviolis suite je fais 10 à
l'antenne
c'est ce qu'on dise il sort des maths de
10,9 centré sur la vie de ma mère c'est
un truc de ouf
vas-y de 30,6 au japon tube merde alors
2e dans les audiences et le karting
d'incroyable talent la france a la
prestance a réuni 4 millions de
téléspectateurs
non c'est 500 milles de plus que la
semaine dernière c'est un énorme une
énorme progression et victor hugo
c'était sur france 3 en troisième
position victor hugo c'est cette série
s'est uni d'état pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas le programme 100 go
c'est une série qui parle de victor hugo
et qui explique que c'est un ennemi
d'état voilà et ça a réuni 2.5 millions
de téléspectateurs le bonus cyril et que
j'ai regardé le programme que personne
ne regarde quoi et c'est evelyne thomas
qui l'incarnent
non j'adore non c'est pas son choix
j'adore c'est un documentaire en fait
qui suit une femme qui sont des femmes
tueuse je vous ai fait le résumé ça
commence par un plat toutes les villes
tombent à regarder bienvenue dans snatch
les femmes tueuse votre émission de
faits divers sur sheridan sale et je
peux vous dire les amis que j'ai passé
une bonne soirée restera avec plein de
monde gestionnaire de la rumeur tout ça
sent le centre matisse meurtre colère
coups de couteau à coups de couteau soit
plus tôt prenez un des blessures et ça
finit le top six cadavres mais regardez
la seule qui n'était pas choqué c'est
victoria qui est tout sourire à la fin
de son émission ambition maintenant
terminé merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
il n ya qu on avait sa lecture tu l'as
vu jingle up
[Applaudissements]
et
jingle sur la tête de ma mère on dirait
qu'il va partir on dirait qu'il va avoir
guy lux qui va arriver je me suis
inspiré une maxime qui n'y aura rien
tous les soirs écho à la journée du
président plein déplacements et dans
cette journée il y avait trois mois à
retenir tout d'abord le mot
carabistouilles non non non cette
itinérance itinérance itinérant cette
itinérance d'itinérance
alors c'est quoi au fait l'itinérance et
bien c'est le fait pour quelqu'un ou
quelque chose défendre déplacement en
mouvement au contraire d'une personne
sédentaire et mouvement le président il
adore alors que le pays ne parle que de
ça prix du carburant la hausse des
carburants flambée des prix des
carburants
pierre durand emmanuel macron a
exceptionnellement fait déplacer tous
ses ministres autrement dit les à
délocaliser délocaliser délocaliser ont
délocalisé et en pleine crise du
carburant déplacer à tous ses ministres
basse et influent c'est gonflé puisque
j'ai les chiffres d'aller sur 17
ministres 17 ministres délocalisé ça
donne ça regardez le conseil des
ministres a lieu d'habitude à l'elysée
il a été délocalisé à charleville
mézières
aujourd'hui c'est 476 km pour aller dans
cette ville 17 minutes 31 litres
d'essence par ministre ce qui nous fait
une facture totale de 790 euros voilà et
cette facture qui va la payer
c'est toi non c'est pas moi c'est pas
toi de sa ville et c'est surtout pas le
président écouter cet alibi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]